ROGERS, ON SUNDAYS, G. MONEY CAN
BE FOUND AT RAIDERS STADIUM.
HE'S THE MAYOR OF MANY PLACES,
SPECIFICALLY LAS VEGAS.
WE DREAMED UP WITH DRAFTKINGS TO
GIVE YOU A LOOK AT OUR FAVORITE
NFL FURESBETS.
WE'RE GIVING OUT 1,000 DK
DOLLARS AND WE HAVE FREE BURGERS
FOR A YEAR COURTESY OF CHAD
OCHOCINCO JOHNSON.
AND WE'RE GETTING YOUR WARDROBES
TIGHT AND WE HAVE SOME HOODIES
TO GIVE AWAY, G. MONEY.
>> CABBIE, FOR ALL THE NEW
PEOPLE THAT TAPPED INTO THE
SHOW, CONNOR, THIS RIGHT HERE IS
THE HANDY iPAD, THIS IS HOW YOU
GUYS GET YOUR HOODIES.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS GIVING AWAY
A HOODIE.
SKATE GOT THE KAMARA GIFT GOING
ON.
>> NICE.
>> THERE IT IS.
YOU CAN SEE IT ON THE SCREEN.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU SKATE, YOU'RE
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
>> LET'S LOOK BACK AT OUR
FAVORITE MOMENTS FROM LAST YEAR
WITH THE HELP OF YOU, OUR FANS.
♪
>> YES!
YES!
DO YOU BELIEVE IN MIRACLES!
♪
>> PURE JOY.
WE CANNOT WAIT FOR THE NFL
SEASON TO START, WHICH IS
SEPTEMBER 9th.
THERE'S PLENTY OF ACTION TO BE
HAD RIGHT NOW.
WE'LL START OFF WITH OUR
FAVORITE FUTURES BETS AND SHOW
YOU WIN TOTALS TO SUPER BOWL
FUTURES TO PLAYER PERFORMANCES.
LET'S START WITH THIS, CONNOR.
WHAT IS THE MOST SURPRISING
THING ABOUT THIS YEAR'S SCHEDULE
DROP?
>> I'M WONDERING WHO WILL KNOCK
DOWN THE DOOR WEEK ONE.
TEAMS ARE MATCHING UP-AND-COMING
IN AND TRYING TO SHOW THEY'RE
FOR REAL.
THE BROWNS GO TO KANSAS CITY.
THERE'S A LOT OF HYPE IN THE
BROWNS RIGHT NOW.
THE CHIEFS DID A GOOD JOB
BUILDING THAT OFFENSIVE LINE UP.
THE BROWNS CAN CHALLENGE IN THE
AFC THIS YEAR.
I WONDER IF THEY SURPRISE SOME
PEOPLE WEEK ONE.
THE BILLS DON'T WANT TO BE KNOWN
AS A ONE-YEAR WONDER.
THEY THINK THEY'RE HERE TO STAY.
WITH JOSH ALLEN, A WELL-COACHED
DEFENSE AGAINST A STEELERS TEAM
THAT PEOPLE ARE WONDERING IS
THIS THE END FOR BIG BEN OR CAN
THEY MAKE ONE MORE SERIOUS RUN
THIS YEAR?
THEY HAVE TO GO TO THE BILLS
MAFIA TO GET THAT DONE.
>> I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE PEOPLE
JUMPING THROUGH TABLES IN
BUFFALO.
WIN TOTALS FOR THE EIGHT MOST
POPULAR TEAMS.
CHICAGO AT THE TOP.
DALLAS, TAMPA BAY, KC, SAN
FRANCISCO, PHILADELPHIA,
PITTSBURGH, CLEVELAND.
THERE'S SOME PLUS MONEY ON THE
BOARD WHICH IS ALWAYS NICE.
THE BIG TEAM MISSING FROM THE
TOP EIGHT IS GREEN BAY.
THE PACKERS ARE OFF THE BOARD
DUE TO UNCERTAINTY WITH AARON
RODGERS.
CONNOR, CAN YOU GIVE US YOUR
BEST SENSE OF WHAT'S GOING ON IN
GREEN BAY AND HOW MANY GAMES IS
AARON RODGERS WORTH TO THE
BETTING MARKET?
>> IT'S A STARE DOWN AND A LOT
CONSIDERING THAT GREEN BAY IS
OFF THE BOARD.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT, ROGERS
TELLING PEOPLE HE DOESN'T PLAN
ON COMING BACK.
GREEN BAY TELLING ANYBODY WHO
WILL CALL THAT WE'RE NOT
PLANNING ON TRADING HIM NOW.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP THE PACKERS OFF
THE BOARD BECAUSE OF THAT.
YOU LOOK AT HOW THAT CAN SHAPE
THINGS UP IN THE AFC.
IF AARON RODGERS ENDS UP ON
DENVER, WHAT DOES THAT WIN TOTAL
END LIKE?
THIS COULD TOTALLY ROCK THE
PRESEASON BETTING WORLD.
I THINK THESE TWO SIDES WILL
STARE AT EACH OTHER LONG.
>> MVP AND "JEOPARDY!" HOST
AARON RODGERS IS GOOD AT
EVERYTHING.
CAN YOU GIVE ME THE COMMENTS
SECTION FOR 200 PLEASE?
>> LET'S PUT THE ODDS BACK UP.
GET THE ODDS BACK UP THERE.
GET IN THE COMMENTS, TELL US
YOUR BEST WIN TOTAL BET.
YOU CAN TELL ME IN WORDS, TELL
ME IN GIFTS, TELL ME IN EMOJIS.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND 250
DK DOLLARS RIGHT NOW.
CONNOR, WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE
WIN TOTAL FUTURE?
>> LET'S NOT FORGET, A 17-GAME
SCHEDULE.
DON'T BE AFRAID OF THAT HIGH
NUMBER FOR THE CHIEFS AT 12 1/2.
GO OVER IT, AND YOU GET REWARDED
FOR BEING BOLD.
TAKE THOSE FAVORABLE ODDS.
DO WE THINK THE CHIEFS ARE GOING
TO LOSE FIVE OR SIX GAMES THIS
YEAR?
BETTER OFFENSIVE LINE?
BEST QUARTERBACK ON THE PLANET.
GREAT HEAD COACH.
A DEFENSE THAT MAKES PLAYS IN A
TIMELY FASHION.
I THINK THE CHIEFS GET 13 WINS.
I KNOW IT'S CRAZY TO GO WITH A
NUMBER THAT HIGH.
I DON'T THINK IT'S THAT BIG OF A
AUTOMOBILE.
>> CONNOR, I LIKE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING.
I'M STICKING IN THE AFC AS WELL.
I'M LOOKING AT THE CLEVELAND
BROWNS WHO HAVE AN IMPROVED
DEFENSE AND PRO FOOTBALL FOCUS
RATES THE CLEVELAND BROWNS
OFFENSIVE LINE AS TOPS IN THE
NFL.
WITH A HEALTHY NICK CHUBB, HE'S
GOOD FOR A DOZEN TOUCHDOWNS.
GIVE ME 11 WINS AND THE PLUS 107
FOR THE CLEVELAND BROWNS.
GREG, WHAT ARE THEY SAYING IN
THE COMMENTS?
>> CABBIE, THE COMMENTS ARE
JUMPING.
I GOT ROLL TIDE GIVING US A
GIFT.
EAGLES DEFENSE PUTTING IN THAT
WORK.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
I HAVE FF FOOTBALL SAYING GREEN
BAY WILL KEEP RODGERS OVER 11
WINS FOR THE PACKERS IF HE'S
THERE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU F FOOTBALL,
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
THIS NEXT COMMENTER, YOU'RE
WALKING AWAY WITH 250 IN DC
DOLLARS.
LITTLE DRUM ROLL.
HERE WE GO.
I HAVE -- I HAVE AK-47 --
>> COME ON.
>> CABBIE, YOU'RE GOING TO THINK
I WAS BEING BIASED HERE, BUT I
WASN'T.
HE SAID THE SAN FRANCISCO 49ers
OVER.
I PROMISE YOU, THAT WAS NOT
BIASED.
THAT WAS STRICTLY FROM THE
COMMENTS.
BUT YOU GUYS, YOU ARE TAKING
OVER.
CABBIE WITH THE CLEVELAND OVER.
CONNOR WITH THE KANSAS CITY
OVER.
I WILL SWITCH IT UP A BIT.
I WILL SWITCH IT UP.
I'LL TAKE THE TAMPA BAY BUCS
UNDER.
PLUS MONEY.
I DO SEE A SUPER BOWL HANGOVER
HERE.
>> OKAY.
>> I SEE A SUPER BOWL HANGOVER
WITH THIS TEAM.
GIVE ME THE UNDER.
I LIKE IT.
IT PLUS MONEY, I'M RIDING IT.
>> I LIKE THAT G. MONEY.
VISIT DRAFTKINGS FOR MORE WINS
TOTALS ODDS AND PLACE YOUR BET.
DRAFTKINGS ARE BASICALLY LETTING
YOU GUYS MOVE THE MARKET.
YOU BET YOUR FAVORITE NFL DRAFT
TOTAL.
WHOEVER HAS THE MOST WIN TOTAL
BETS WILL HAVE ONE WIN TOTAL
KNOCKED OFF.
THE CURRENT LEAD IS MINNESOTA.
SO MINNESOTA FAN BASE IS
FLOODING DK.
WE LIKE TO SEE IT WITH
WASHINGTON AND CHICAGO CLOSE
BEHIND.
SO, GET IN THERE AND BET YOUR
FAVORITE WIN TOTAL TO MOVE THE
LINE.
IF YOU DIDN'T GET THOSE DK
DOLLARS, DON'T WORRY, WE'RE
GIVING AWAY MORE STUFF RIGHT
NOW, G. MONEY.
>> YES, SIR.
WE TAPPED WITH CHAD AND ASKED
HIM TO PREDICT THE WIN TOTAL FOR
THE BENGALS NEXT SEASON.
THE CURRENT LINE IS AT 6 1/2.
GET IN THE COMMENTS, DROP OVER
OR UNDER.
TELL ME WHETHER YOU THINK CHAD
HAS FAITH IN THE BENGALS OR IF
HE DOESN'T.
IF YOU KNOW 85, YOU KNOW HIM
WELL, HE LOVES TO EAT
McDONALD'S.
HE LOVES HIS McDONALD'S.
SO WE'RE GIVING OUT $100 IN
McDONALD'S MONEY COURTESY OF
CHAD JOHNSON TO WHOEVER GUESSES
CORRECTLY.
CONNOR, CONNOR, DO YOU THINK
THAT THE BENGALS WILL GO OVER OR
UNDER 6 1/2 WINS?
>> I WILL GO UNDER.
TOUGH DIVISION.
WE KNOW JOE BOROUGH IS COMING
OFF AN INJURY.
WE'RE WONDERING WHEN HE'LL BE A
FULL GO.
I LOVE THEY TOOK JA'MARR CHASE,
BUT I DON'T THINK THEY GET TO
THAT SEVEN-WIN MARK YET.
THAT'S A LOT TO ASK WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE BROWNS AND THE
RAVENS IN YOUR OWN DIVISION.
A GOOD CONFERENCE WHERE THE
SCHEDULE WON'T DO THEM FAVORS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT, THAT'S HOW
I FEEL.
I THINK CHAD WILL BET WITH
EMOTION AND HEART HERE AND HE'LL
GO THE OTHER WAY.
>> CONNOR HAS CINCINNATI UNDER
6 1/2 WINS.
LET'S GO TO THE VIDEO TO SEE HOW
CHAD FEELS ABOUT HIS BENGALS.
>> KNOWING BOROUGH, WHO HAD ONE
OF HIS BEST SEASONS AT LSU
BEFORE HE LEFT WAS WITH WHO?
JA'MARR CHASE.
BENGAL ALSO HAVE OVER EIGHT
WINS.
BOOK IT.
>> MY GUY.
>> I THINK HE SMOKED ABOUT 85 OF
THOSE 85 CIGARS.
>> CHAD SAID OVER 8 WINS,
SOMEONE WHO SAID OVER 8 WINS
WILL WALK AWAY WITH McDONALD'S
MONEY.
I'LL GET IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW.
HERE WE GO.
I GOT M GO BLUE, 16.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I ALSO HAVE EVAN, EVAN L.K., WAY
OVER 6 1/2.
AND WITH THE BURGER EMOJI,
SHOUTS OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CABBIE, TIME TO GET TO THIS $100
IN McDONALD'S MONEY COURTESY OF
CHAD JOHNSON.
SHAQUILLE!
SHAQUILLE OATMEAL, YOU ARE THE
WINNER --
>> OUTSTANDING HANDLE.
>> COURTESY OF CHAD JHONAOH
J.
SHOUT OUT TO SHAQUILLE OATMEAL.
>> HOPEFULLY HE CAN GET AN EGG
McMUFFIN OR WHATEVER BREAKFAST
TREATS YOU LIKE.
GET THEM ALL AT McDONALD'S.
WE HAVE MORE TO GIVE AWAY
INCLUDING A FREE YEAR OF BURGERS
COURTESY OF CHAD OCHOCINCO.
LET'S TALK THE ODDS TO WIN THE
DIVISION.
WE'RE LOOKING AT ONE OF THE MOST
HOTLY CONTESTED DIVISIONS, THE
NFC LEAST.
NONE OF THESE TEAMS GOT TO .500
LAST YEAR.
DALLAS IS THE BETTING FAVORITE
AT PLUS 125.
WASHINGTON FOOTBALL TEAM, PLUS
260.
THE FOOTBALL GIANTS FROM NEW
YORK, PLUS 350.
THEN PHILADELPHIA AT PLUS 500.
HOW DOES THE AUDIENCE FEEL ABOUT
THE NFC LEAST?
>> LET ME ASK THEM.
I LIKE HOW YOU CALL THEM THE NFC
LEAST.
GET IN THE COMMENTS, TELL US WHO
YOU THINK IS A LOCK TO WIN THE
NFC LEAST.
YOU CAN GET CREATIVE.
THERE'S FOUR DIDNFFERENT TEAMS
THE CONFERENCE.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND 250
DK DOLLARS THIS TIME.
CONNOR, WHAT'S YOUR TAKE?
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT,
CONSIDERING YOU GET FAVORABLE
ODDS FOR WHOEVER YOU BET, I
THINK THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHO WILL
WIN THIS DIVISION EITHER.
I LOVE WASHINGTON.
I LOOK AT THE FOOTBALL TEAM AND
JUST SEE THE MOST COMPLETE TEAM
ACROSS THE BOARD IN THIS ENTIRE
DIVISION.
I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
DEFENSE, YOU HAD WILLIAM
JACKSON.
NOW A SHUTDOWN CORNER.
A FRONT FOUR THAT GETS AFTER THE
QUARTERBACK.
THE QUARTERBACKS HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTION MARKS IN THIS DIVISION.
THEY HAVE MORE ATHLETICISM IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE FIELD.
RYAN FITZPATRICK CAN GET THOSE
WEAPONS WORKING DOWN THE FIELD.
THEY HAVE A RUN GAME AND AN
IMPROVED OFFENSIVE LINE.
WASHINGTON FOOTBALL TEAM PLUS
260, THAT MIGHT BE ONE OF MY
FAVORITE FUTURES BETS AVAILABLE
RIGHT NOW.
>> CONNOR, HOW MUCH MAGIC DO YOU
THINK FITZMAGIC HAS LEFT?
THE GUY IS LIKE 40.
>> HE HAD IT FOR MIAMI LAST
YEAR.
HE HAD TO BE THE CLOSER FOR TWO
OF THEM
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, I REALLY WANT TO TAKE
PHILADELPHIA.
L
I LOOK AT THE PLUS .500.
THE ODDS ARE JUICY, BUT THERE'S
SO MUCH PRESSURE TO PUT ON JALEN
HURTS, A QUARTERBACK WHO ONLY
PLAYED FOUR GAMES IN THE NFL.
I'LL GO TO THE TOP OF THE BOARD.
THE TEAM THAT BROUGHT IN A NEW
DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR AND WILL
HAVE A PAIR OF HEALTHY TACKLES
IN COLLINS AND SMITH.
THIS SQUAD USED 8 OF ITS 11
DRAFT PICKS TO ADDRESS THE
POOREST DEFENSE THAT WE SAW IN
2020.
I'M GOING WITH THE COWBOYS.
I KNOW THAT MAKES ME A
CHALK-EATING WEASEL, BUT I THINK
THE COWBOYS TAKE THE NFC EAST.
GIVE ME THAT AT PLUS 125.
WHAT ARE THEY SAYING ON THE
iPAD?
>> THEY'RE GETTING CREATIVE IN
THE COMMENTS.
THEY'RE GETTING CREATIVE.
I GOT MILWAUKEE 1919 SAYING
COWBOYS WILL BE UNDER .500.
WASHINGTON FOOTBALL TEAM TO WIN
THE DIVISION.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU MILWAUKEE 1919.
I GOT CONNOR GRANT, NOT CONNOR
RODGERS, BUT CONNOR GRANT IN THE
COMMENTS SAYING THE FOOTBALL
TEAM.
HE'S WORKING WITH YOU AND THE
FOOTBALL TEAM.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
IT'S TIME TO GIVE AWAY THESE 250
DK DOLLARS.
IT'S TIME TO GIVE AWAY 250 DK
DOLLARS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS AND I SEE
CHRIS 12C.
HE SAYS COWBOYS.
HE HAS THE DAK PRESCOTT GIFT.
HOPEFULLY IT DOESN'T LEAVE THE
SCREEN.
DAK PRESCOTT, THERE IT IS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, CHRIS.
LET ME GET MY PICK IN HERE.
I WILL ROCK WITH MY GUY, CONNOR.
THE WASHINGTON FOOTBALL TEAM,
FITZMAGIC, YOU ASKED DOES HE
HAVE MAGIC.
I THINK HE HAS SOME MAGIC LEFT.
THIS DEFENSE IS PUT TOGETHER.
THE FRONT FOUR IS NASTY.
CHASE YOUNG, MONTEZ SWEAT,
JONATHAN ALLEN, DURANTE, THEY'RE
NUMBER TWO IN TOTAL YARDS
ALLOWED LAST YEAR.
THEY ONLY GOT BETTER.
THEY DRAFTED A LINEBACKER.
THIS DEFENSE PUT TOGETHER.
I LIKE FITZMAGIC.
CURTIS SAMUEL COMING OVER.
THE THREE-HEADED MONSTER IN THE
BACKFIELD.
GIVE IT TO ME.
GIVE IT TO ME, PLEASE.
I LIKE THE WASHINGTON REDSKINS
PLUS TWO.
>> YOU GUYS SPEAK WITH SO MUCH
CONFIDENCE, I MIGHT CHANGE MY
TAKE.
I HAVE A BIT OF TIME.
THE SEASON IS FOUR MONTHS AWAY.
YOU GUYS ARE GIVING ME SOMETHING
TO THINK ABOUT.
FOR THE REST OF YOU GUYS, VISIT
DRAFTKINGS FOR THE REMAINING
SEVEN DIVISION ODDS.
IT'S TIME TO GIVE AWAY MORE
BURGERS, G. MONEY.
WHO'S READY TO EAT.
>> WE ASKED CHAD FOR HIS LOCK TO
WIN THE NFC EAST.
GET IN THE COMMENTS, TELL US WHO
YOU THINK T.O. PICKED.
IS HE RIDING WITH HIS FAVORITE?
THE COWBOYS?
IS HE SPRINKLING MONEY ON THE
EAGLES?
WE'RE GIVING AWAY $100 IN
McDONALD'S MONEY, COURTESY OF MY
GUY, 85.
WHOEVER GUESSES CORRECTLY,
CONNOR, WHO DO YOU THINK T.O.
PICKED?
DO YOU THINK HE TOOK THE EAGLES
OR THE COWBOYS?
DO YOU THINK HE TOOK A DIFFERENT
TEAM?
>> I THINK HE'S RUNNING BACK TO
THE STARS.
HE'S GOING WITH THE FAVORITE IN
THE COWBOYS.
IT'S GOING TO BE A TOUGH TOSS-UP
FOR HIM.
HE'S GOT A LITTLE EAGLES BIAS
MAYBE, COWBOYS BIAS.
BUT I THINK HE'LL ROCK WITH
DALLAS IN THIS SITUATION.
>> CONNOR SAYS TERRELL OWENS
WILL LEAD DALLAS.
LET'S SEE WHO T.O. PICKED.
>> THEY CAN'T SEE YOUR FACE BUT
THEY CAN HEAR YOUR VOICE.
>> MY VOICE IS GOOD.
>> HE'S IN THE DARK.
ARE YOU SLEEPING?
WILL THE COWBOYS MAKE THE
PLAYOFFS?
THEY GOT ALL THAT FIRE POWER ON
OFFENSE.
>> THAT'S -- I'LL SAY YES.
>> WIN THE NFC EAST?
>> NO.
>> WHAT?
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY COMPETITION.
>> EAGLES.
EAGLES GOT JALEN HURTS.
HE'S ALWAYS GOING TO PUT THEM IN
CONTENTION.
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
WAIT A MINUTE.JALEN HURTS
HAS TO COMPETE FOR THE STARTING
JOB.
DO THEY HAVE FAITH IN HIM?
>> I HAVE FAITH IN HIM.
HE'S A COMPETITOR.
I KNOW WHAT HE'S MADE OF.
>> T.O. IS ASLEEP.
YOU CAN'T EVEN SEE HIM.
WHAT HE DID DO WAS HE ENHANCED
WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY BECAUSE
OF HIS GOOD LOOKS.
>> MY GUY, MY GUY, T.O., TOOK
THE EAGLES.
THAT MEANS ONE OF YOU WHO SAID
EAGLES IS WALKING AWAY WITH $100
IN McDONALD'S MONEY COURTESY OF
CHAD JOHNSON HIMSELF.
I'M GOING TO GET INTO THE
COMMENTS.
I WILL GET INTO THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW.
BR BETTING IS IN THE COMMENTS.
THEY SAID THEY'RE TAKING THE
FOOTBALL TEAM.
SHOUT OUT TO BR BETTING.
RYAN RAY SAYS PHILLY.
ROCKING WITH PHILLY.
ROCKING WITH PHILLY AND MY GUY
T.O.
HERE WE GO.
GOT ONE MORE.
I GOT MICHAEL RITTER.
HE SAYS THE EAGLES COACH CAN'T
EVEN READ.
SAYS THE EAGLES COACH CAN'T EVEN
READ.
THE TWO PEOPLE THAT I JUST
MENTIONED, YOU TWO ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH HOODIES.
NOW THIS ONE IS FOR THE $100.
>> OKAY.
>> CONNOR, YOU GUYS READY?
LET ME GET INTO THIS HANDY
DANDY.
WE HAVE COAST THAT RICA MARK.
HE TOOK THE EAGLES AND IS
WINNING THOSE McDOLLARS.
I HOPE I CAN GET TO COSTA RICA
THIS SUMMER.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH $100 IN
McDONALD'S MONEY.
>> THE LAST TIME PHILADELPHIA
WON THE NFC WAS IN 2017.
THAT WAS ON THE STRENGTH OF SOME
BIG ENERGY.
LET'S TALK CONFERENCE WINNERS.
HERE ARE THE ODDS TO WIN THE NFC
CHAMPIONSHIP.
THE DEFENDING SUPER BOWL
CHAMPIONS, BUCCANEERS AT THE TOP
AT PLUS 300.
L.A. RAMS, PLUS 600.
SAN FRANCISCO, G. MONEY'S TEAM,
PLUS 650.
THERE'S GREEN BAY AT PLUS 800
WITH OR WITHOUT AARON RODGERS.
DALLAS, SEATTLE, NEW ORLEANS,
MINNESOTA, ODDS ARE LONGER.
STILL GREAT TEAMS.
GREG, HOW MANY PEOPLE IN THE
COMMENTS THINK TAMPA BAY WILL
RUN IT BACK?
>> CABBIE, LET ME ASK THEM.
LET ME ASK THEM.
PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS, LET ME
KNOW IF YOU THINK TOBACCO WILL
RUN TOBACC
AMPA BAY WILL
RUN IT BACK.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND 250
BK DOLLARS THIS TIME.
CONNOR, YOU SEE THAT TEAM LISTED
THIRD?
LOOKING JUICY.
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
TALK TO ME, CONNOR, WHO DO YOU
THINK IS COMING OUT OF THE NFC?
>> I WILL AGREE WITH YOUR SUPER
BOWL HANG HANGOVER THEORY.
I'M NOT TAKING THE BUCKS AT PLUS
300.
YOU'RE RISKING A LOT THERE.
I LIKE THE RAMS, PLUS 600.
YOU LOOK AT MATT STAFFORD THERE
WITH SEAN McVAY.
SURE THEY LOST SOME COACHES ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BALL.
STILL THE BEST DEFENSIVE PLAYER
ON THE PLANET IN AARON DONALD.
I THINK STAFFORD TAKES THIS
OFFENSE INTO THE NEXT LEVEL
WORKING WITH McVAY.
WE KNOW WHEN THINGS ARE CLICKING
ON OFFENSE BETWEEN SEAN McVAY
AND HIS QUARTERBACK, HE CAN GET
BACK TO THE PROMISE LAND.
LOVE THE RAMS AT PLUS 600.
>> SOLID PICK.
I DON'T HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THIS
PICK.
I WAS -- THERE'S A WHOLE LOT OF
CONSTERNATION WHEN I WAS
CHOOSING THIS.
I WANTED TO GET THE VALUE PLAY.
I WANT THE LONG SHOT.
I WANT AN UNDERDOG TO ROOT FOR.
SO NEW ORLEANS.
THEY HAVE A MIDDLE OF THE ROAD
STRENGTH OF SCHEDULE.
THEY HAVE A TOP FIVE CALIBER
DEFENSE.
HERE'S THE BIG THING.
ALVIN KAMARA IS ALL WORLD.
BUT MICHAEL THOMAS, IF HE'S
HEALTHY FOR THE WHOLE SEASON,
THEN JAMEIS WINSTON CAN BALL
OUT.
I'M NOT SAYING 30 TOUCHDOWNS, 30
INTERCEPTIONS.
MAYBE 35 TOUCHDOWNS, MUCH LESS
THAN 30 INTERCEPTIONS.
HE'S ON A ONE-YEAR DEAL.
YOU KNOW HE'S GUNNING FOR A NEW
CONTRACT.
SO GIVE ME THE NEW ORLEANS
SAINTS AT PLUS 1400 TO BEEN THE
NFC CHAMPIONS.
G. MONEY, WHAT ARE THEY SAYING
IN THE COMMENTS?
WILL YOU PLEASE TELL US WHICH
TEAM YOU'RE ROOTING FOR?
>> I'M GOING TO GET IN THESE
COMMENTS, BUT DO YOU REALLY
THINK JAMEIS WINSTON IS GOING TO
WIN THE CHAMPIONSHIP?
>> HE'S GOT A HUGE ARM.
HE'S GOT WEAPONS.
ALVIN KAMARA.
WE SAW IT LAST YEAR.
>> IS HE EVEN GOING TO START?
>> IS HE GOING TO START?
YEAH.
>> TASOYSON HILL IS THERE, HE'S
FAVORITE, BUT IT'S JAMEIS
WINSTON.
>> SIDE BET, WEEK ONE?
>> WEEK ONE STARTING?
YEAH, I'LL PUT 100 ON THAT.
>> 100 ON IT.
LET ME GET TO THESE COMMENTS
BEFORE THE PRODUCER GETS INTO MY
EAR.
JALENE SAYS TOM BRADY AND THE
BUCCA
BUCCANEERS.
THEY HAVE THE GIFT OF HIM
WALKING OUT OF THE PARADE WHERE
HE WAS BEING HELD UP BY ONE OF
HIS TEAMMATES.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT SEAN ROWEN 54 WHO SAYS
SEATTLE.
WOW.
THREW A CURVEBALL THERE.
SEATTLE.
SEAN ROWEN, 54, YOU'RE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
LET ME GIVE YOU THE 250 OF THESE
DK DOLLARS REAL QUICK.
250 OF THESE DK DOLLARS.
HERE WE GO.
I SEE MICHAEL RITTER IN THE
COMMENTS.
NOT GOING TO GIVE IT TO MICHAEL.
DOWN TO EARTH.
HE'S THROWING A LITTLE SHADE AT
ME BUT ROCKING WITH YOU, CABBIE.
THEREFORE I WILL GIVE YOU THE
250 DK DOLLARS.
DOWN TO EARTH.
THE SAINTS GOT IT.
HE'S CONFIRMING WHAT YOU JUST
SAID.
>> DOWN TO EARTH, LET'S GO,
BABY.
>> WITH ALL THAT BEING SAID,
THERE WAS A TEAM THAT WAS LISTED
THIRD ON THE LIST PLUS 650, THE
SAN FRANCISCO 49ers THAT I
STRONGLY BELIEVE THIS YEAR
RANKED ON PAPER -- MATCHED ON
PAPER AGAINST ANYBODY IN THE
LEAGUE, WE'RE RIGHT THERE.
THE SAN FRANCISCO 49ers ARE
RIGHT THERE ON PAPER.
WE'RE JUST A QUARTERBACK AWAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
TRAY LANCE IS BEHIND THEM.
JIMMY HAS COMPETITION.
WE'RE GOING TO LET THE CARDS
PLAY THEMSELVES.
WE'LL SEE HOW IT GOES.
CONNOR SAID SOMETHING ABOUT SEAN
McVAY CLICKING WITH HIS
QUARTERBACKS.
YOU CAN ALSO SAY THE SAME THING
ABOUT KYLE SHANAHAN CLICKING
WITH QUARTERBACKS.
IF HE CLICKS WITH A QUARTERBACK
WITH THE DEFENSE THAT WE HAVE
AND ALSO THE OFFENSIVE
PLAYMAKERS THAT WE HAVE, KITTLE,
DIDN'T NAME HIM.
BUT, HEY, WE'LL BE RIGHT THERE.
WE'LL BE RIGHT THERE.
SO TAKE -- TAKE THE NINERS PLUS
650.
WE ALSO PLAY THE RAMS TOUGH.
NINERS PLAY THE RAMS TOUGH.
THAT'S WHY I'M LEANING THIS WAY.
I ALSO THINK TAMPA BAY WILL HAVE
THE HANGOVER YEAR.
>> YOU CAN TELL GREG IS FROM THE
BAY AREA.
HE SAID WE, REFERRING TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO 49ers.
VISIT DRAFTKINGS FOR THE
REMAINING NFC CHAMPIONSHIP ODDS.
SEAN PAYTON, I KNOW HE LOVE
S
TAYSON HILL, BUT IT'S THE JAMEIS
WINSTON ERA.
BURGERS ARE A STATEMENT OF
OCHO'S DIET AND SHARING IS
CARING.
SO WHO WANTS THESE DELICIOUS
CA
CARBS?
>> WE ASKED CHAD FOR HIS LOCK TO
WIN THE AFC.
LET'S LOOK AT THE MENU.
THERE IT IS.
KANSAS CITY SITTING AT PLUS 260.
BUFFALO, WOW.
BUFFALO PLUS 625.
CONNOR, YOU SEE CLEVELAND, PLUS
750.
GET IN THE COMMENTS, TELL US
WHAT TEAM YOU THINK CHAD PICKED.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY $100 TO ONE OF
YOU WHO GUESSES CORRECTLY.
WHILE YOU VOTE, TELL US WHO DO
YOU LIKE TO WIN THE AFC?
THIS IS $100 IN McDONALD'S
MONEY.
I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT.
CONNOR, WHO DO YOU WANT TO WIN
OUT OF THE AFC?
>> I LIKE THOSE BROWNS ODDS,
PLUS 750.
WHO KNEW WE WOULD BE LIVING IN
THIS YEAR AND SAYING I LIKE THE
BROWNS YARDS.
THEY BUILT A PHENOMENAL ROSTER.
THEY GOT IT RIGHT IN THE COACH
WITH KEVIN STEFANSKI.
THEY DO TWO THINGS THAT TRAVEL
IN THE PLAYOFFS AND LEAD TO
SUPER BOWL APPEARANCES, THEY RUN
THE BALL AND THEY'LL PLAY
DEFENSE.
THEY HAVE A GOOD FIRST ROUND
CORNER IN GREG NEWSOM, MYLES
GARRETT IS A BEAST OFF THE EDGE.
HE WILL HAVE A CAREER YEAR.
THIS OFFENSE WILL BE EFFICIENT
ENOUGH TO KEEP WINNING GAMES.
I KNOW IT'S CRAZY TO SAY,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE CHIEFS
SITTING UP THERE, THE RAVENS
ALWAYS AROUND.
I LOVE WHAT THE BILLS MAFIA HAS
DONE OVER THE YEARS.
I WILL GO WITH THE LONG SHOT,
THAT'S THE BROWNS.
>> CONNOR SAYS THE CLEVELAND
BROWNS TO WIN THE AFC
CHAMPIONSHIP.
LET'S CHECK THE TAPE AND SEE IF
OCHOCINCO IS GOING OUT ON A LIMB
AS WELL.
>> MY LOCK TO WIN THE AFC IS --
THE CHIEFS.
IT BURNS ME TO SAY THAT.
BUT OKAY.
♪
>> CHAD TOOK THE CHIEFS.
CHAD TOOK THE CHIEFS, MEANING
SOMEONE WHO SAID KANSAS CITY IN
THE COMMENTS IS WALKING AWAY
WITH $100 IN McDONALD'S MONEY
COURTESY OF CHAD JOHNSON
HIMSELF.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
I GOT SWEENA, SWEENA IS ASKING
THE COMMENTS ON WHAT ARE WE
BETTING ON?
>> WHAT AREN'T WE BETTING ON?
>> WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
WE'RE TALKING FUTURES.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
YOU JUST WALKED INTO THE SHOW
BUT YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
WOW!
YOU'RE GENEROUS TODAY.
>> KEEN 12, BURGER AND AMERICAN
THINGS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANT,
BUT THEY TAPPED IN.
CABBIE, IT'S TIME TO GIVE AWAY
THAT $100 AND THAT McDONALD'S
MONEY.
ARE YOU READY?
>> YES, SIR.
>> ARE YOU READY?
>> IN THE COMMENTS, MY GUY, RYAN
RAY, WON A HOODIE.
HE IS ALSO WALKING AWAY WITH
SOME McDONALD'S MONEY.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU RYAN FOR BEING
HERE AND TAPPING IN TO THE
DROPZONE.
RYAN RAY IS WALKING AWAY WITH
$100 IN McDONALD'S MONEY
COURTESY OF CHAD JOHNSON.
>> THE AUDIENCE LOVES IT WHEN
YOU'RE THIS GENEROUS.
SINCE THE YEAR 2000 ONLY FOUR
PLAYERS HAVE WON THE NFL MVP WHO
ARE NOT QUARTERBACKS.
THERE ARE ONLY QUARTERBACKS ON
THIS SHORT LIST OF POTENTIAL NFL
MVPs.
LET'S SEE THE MENU HERE.
WE HAVE A BUNCH OF FORMER MVPs,
PATRICK MAHOAHOMES, AARON BRADY
TOM BRADY, LAMAR JACKSON.
THIS IS A DECORATED LIST.
WE HAVE JUSTIN HERBERT WHO IS
THE 2020 ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
GREG, YOU'RE OUR MVP.
I DON'T SEE YOUR ODDS ON THE
BOARD.
WHO IS GETTING THE MOST MVP LOVE
IN THE COMMENTS?
>> WE HAVE TO FIGURE THAT OUT.
>> WE DO.
>> NAH, JUST KIDDING.
>> I NEED YOU TO DO ME A FAVOR.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND LET ME
KNOW WHO YOU THINK IS A LOCK TO
BE MVP.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND THIS
TIME 250 DK DOLLARS.
YOU SAW THE LIST.
IT'S JUICY.
STARS ALL AROUND THE LIST.
WHERE ARE YOU LEANING TOWARDS
MVP THIS SEASON?
>> I'VE BEEN GIVING YOU LONG
SHOTS ALL SHOW.
WE'RE KEEPING IT SIMPLE HERE AND
GOING WITH PATRICK MAHOMES.
HE'S THE BEST QUARTERBACK IN THE
ENTIRE UNIVERSE, PLUS 500?
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE MUCH
TOUGHER THAN THAT.
CABBIE SAID IT, THIS IS THE MOST
VALUABLE QUARTERBACK AWARD AND
NOTHING ELSE.
DON'T WASTE YOUR TIME WITH
ANYONE ELSE IN THAT REGARD.
MAHOMES WILL COME BACK PISSED
OFF THIS YEAR.
I THINK HE WOULD HAVE FELT THEY
SHOULD HAVE HAD BACK-TO-BACK
SUPER BOWLS, TOUGH BREAK FOR
HIM.
THEY FIXED THEIR UNIT.
MAHOMES PLUS 500, PRETTY SWEET.
>> YOU SAID MAHOMES MIGHT BE
PISSED OFF?
WE SAW WHAT A PISSED OFF AARON
RODGERS DID IN 2020.
AARON RODGERS IN 2021, STILL
PISSED OFF.
THE DISRESPECT IN GREEN BAY IS
CRAZY.
THAT WILL FUEL HIS FIRE.
IF HE REMAINS WITH GREEN BAY, I
THINK HE'LL GET HIS FOURTH MVP
TROPHY.
WE SAW WHAT HE COULD DO LAST
YEAR AND THE SQUAD WASN'T ALL
THE WAY HEALTHY.
I LIKE AARON RODGERS AT PLUS 900
AND SPRINKLE A LITTLE ON DAK
PRESCOTT.
WHO IS GETTING LOVE IN THE
COMMENTS?
>> CABBIE, BEFORE I GET TO MINE,
LET ME GET BACK INTO THE
COMMENTS.
ROLL TIDE IS RIDING WITH PACTRIK
MAHOMES.
YOU ALREADY HAVE A HOODIE.
BUT THANK YOU FOR TAPPING IN.
MEECH NORRIS, JUSTIN HERBERT.
>> WOW.
>> THAT'S A LONG SHOT.
>> I LIKE THAT.
KEN G., JUSTIN HERBERT.
I LIKE THAT A LOT.
KEVIN -- NOT KEVIN, CABBIE, I'M
SO SORRY, EVAN, I COMBINED YOUR
TWO NAMES.
CABBIE, HE SAID JAMIE WINSTON
FOR MVP.
THAT GOES ALONG WITH YOUR FUTURE
BET OF WINNING THE SUPER BOWL.
LET ME GIVE AWAY THIS 250 DK
DOLLARS REAL QUICK.
THIS 250 DK DOLLARS.
I HAVE RITCHIE 21 WITH THE
RUSSELL WILSON GIFT.
HERE WE GO.
RIGHT THERE.
RUSSELL WILSON WALKING DOWN,
SLAPPING HANDS WITH HIS
TEAMMATES.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, I'LL HAVE
TO AGREE WITH MY GUY CONNOR
RODGERS HERE.
PAT MAHOMES, IT'S LIKE HE'S
PLAYING MADDEN OUT THERE ON
SUNDAYS.
DROPPING BACK, ROLLING LEFT,
ROLLING BACK RIGHT, THEN
THROWING 50 YARDS DOWN THE
FIELD.
HE DOES IT EVERY SUNDAY IT SEEMS
LIKE.
GO ON YOUTUBE.
GO ON YOUTUBE AND SEARCH PATRICK
MAHOMES AND THAT WILL TELL YOU
WHY YOU SHOULD BET ON HIM FOR
MVP THIS SEASON.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, I SAW MY
GUY, JUSTIN HERBERT, WORTH A
LITTLE SPRINKLE.
>> OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
>> BUT I LIKE PAT.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PLAYERS
HAVE GONE FROM ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR TO MVP.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S EVER BEEN
DONE IN THE NFL, THAT WOULD BE
QUITE A FEAT FOR THE CHARGERS
QUARTERBACK.
VISIT DRAFTKINGS FOR MORE PLAYER
FUTURES INCLUDING ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY AMERICA'S
FAVORITE FOOD FROM AMERICA'S
FAVORITE AMBASSADOR.
BURGERS FROM CHAD JOHNSON.
WE HAVE A FRESH CROP OF ROOKIES.
DO WE HAVE SOME ROOKIES IN THE
COMMENTS?
>> WE PROBABLY DO.
WELCOME TO ALL THE ROOKIES.
WE ASKED CHAD FOR HIS LOCK TO
WIN OFFENSIVE ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR.
LET'S LOOK AT THE MENU.
THIS MENU, IT'S FILLED.
FILLED WITH A LOT OF ROOKIES.
OBVIOUSLY, IT'S ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR BUT SOME TALENTED GUYS
HERE.
TREVOR LAWRENCE AT PLUS 300.
TRAY LANCE, PLUS 600.
THE ZACH WILSON, CONNOR, YOU SEE
ZACH WILSON THERE?
HE'S SUPPOSED TO BE STARTING
THIS YEAR.
NAJI HARRIS.
TELL US WHO YOU THINK CHAD
PICKED TO WIN ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY $100 IN
McDONALD'S MONEY.
CONNOR, WHO DO YOU LIKE?
>> I'M GETTING AWAY FROM THE
QUARTERBACKS.
WE'RE GOING WITH NAJI HARRIS.
GOES THROUGH A LANDING SPOT THAT
THEY WILL LOVE TO RUN THE BALL
WITH HIM AS THE 1A KIND OF GUY.
HE NEVER HAS TO COME OFF THE
FIELD.
THREE-DOWN RUNNER, PACATCH THE
BALL, PASS PROTECT.
YOU LOOK FOR WHAT THEIR
PRODUCTION CAN BE OUT OF THE
GATE.
I KNOW TREVOR LAWRENCE WILL
START AND ZACH WILSON WILL
START.
IF WE KNEW TRAY LANCE WAS
STARTING WEEK ONE, THAT'S WHERE
MY MONEY WOULD GO.
THAT'S TOO MUCH UP IN THE AIR.
NAJI HARRIS, PLUS 800.
HE COULD BE A TOP FIVE MOST
PRODUCTIVE RUNNING BACK IN THE
LEAGUE RIGHT AWAY.
>> I LOVE IT.
NAJI HARRIS FOR THE STEELERS.
LET'S SEE IF CHAD IS ROLLING
WITH THE WORKHORSE RUNNING BACK.
>> YO, MY LOCK ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR IS DeVONTA SMITH.
>> CHAD.
>> OF COURSE HE WOULD PICK A
RECEIVER.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
YOU KNOW HE WOULD TAKE DeVONTA,
ESPECIALLY SOMEBODY WHO IS NOT
PHYSICAL AND CAN GET OFF THE
LINE AND USE HIS FEET.
THAT'S WHAT CHAD DID BACK IN THE
DAY.
YOU KNOW HE'LL TRY TO TAKE
SOMEBODY LIKE THAT.
HE TOOK DeVONTA.
SOMEONE WHO SAID DeVONTA SMITH
IN THE COMMENTS IS GOING HOME
WITH $100 IN McDONALD'S MONEY.
I'M ABOUT TO GET INTO THE
COMMENTS.
FIRST I WILL GIVE AWAY HOM
HOODHOO
SOME
HOODIES.
I HAVE F. FOOTBALL SAYS FIELDS
AND CHASE ARE GREAT PICKS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
JULIE FOOTBALL SAYS I WAS THE
ONLY ONE SAYING SMITH, BABY.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, JULIE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
I ALSO HAVE B. HOLTE, HE SAYS
DeVONTA ADAMS -- NO, NO, I'M
THINKING ABOUT TAY.
DeVONTA SMITH.
HOPEFULLY DeVONTA SMITH TURNS
OUT TO BE LIKE TAY, WE'LL SEE.
SHOUT OUT TO JULIE FOR SAYING
DeVONTA SMITH AND THE OTHER
PERSON, THE PRODUCER IS GOING TO
TELL ME WHO WON.
WE'RE MOVING ON, CABBIE.
WE HAVE TO SEE WHO WILL WALK
AWAY WITH THIS $100 IN
McDONALD'S MONEY.
WE HAVE TO SEE WHO WILL WALK
AWAY WITH THIS $100 IN
McDONALD'S MONEY.
I'LL GOING TO GIVE IT TO JULIE.
>> OKAY.
>> JULIE FOOTBALL.
SHE TOOK SMITH AND IS WALKING
AWAY WITH THE $100 IN McDONALD'S
MONEY.
SQUU
JULIE, YOU WERE RIGHT.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
SUPER BOWL LVI IS SCHEDULED FOR
FEBRUARY 13th IN LOS ANGELES.
WHICH TEAM WILL BE THERE TO
HOIST THE LOMBARDI TROPHY?
LET'S SEE THE ODDS.
THESE ARE THE CHAMPIONSHIP
CONTENDERS.
IT STARTS TOP TWO, A REMATCH OF
SUPER BOWL LV.
KANSAS CITY, 525, TAMPA BAY AT
650.
THEN BUFFALO AT PLUS 1300.
BUFFALO IS A DARLING IT FEELS
LIKE THIS YEAR.
RAMS AT PLUS 1300.
BALTIMORE, SAN FRANCISCO,
CLEVELAND AND GREEN BAY ROUNDING
OUT THE LIST.
GREG, WHAT DO YOU WANT THE
AUDIENCE TO DO HERE WITH THESE
CHAMPIONSHIP CONTENDERS?
>> GET IN THE COMMENTS, TELL US
WHO IS A LOCK TO WIN THE SUPER
BOWL.
YOU COULD TELL ME IN EMOJIS,
TELL ME RAISING TROPHIES AND
GIFS.
I DON'T KNOW.
YOU GUYS GET CREATIVE.
YOU GUYS ALWAYS COME BACK WITH
CREATIVE THINGS.
TELL ME WHO YOU THINK WILL WIN
THE NFL CHAMPIONSHIP.
I'M GIVING AWAY 250 DK DOLLARS
THIS TIME.
CONNOR, WHO DO YOU LIKE THE MOST
TO WIN THE CHAMPIONSHIP THIS
YEAR.
>> I LIKE THE RAMS.
THE PACKERS CAN FIGURE THIS
THING OUT WITH AARON RODGERS, I
KNOW THOSE ODDS WILL SPIKE UP.
OF COURSE THEY WILL.
THEY WON'T GO UP ENOUGH.
THAT'S THE ONE I HAVE MY EYES
ON.
GOING ON THE BET TODAY, MAKING
THAT DECISION TODAY, I WILL ROLL
WITH THE RAMS.
I'M BELIEVING IN THE MAGIC
BETWEEN McVAY AND MATT STAFFORD.
THAT DEFENSE HAS BEEN PLAYING
TOGETHER FOR A LONG TIME.
THE CHIEFS AND THE BUCS, YOU
ALWAYS HAVE TO WONDER WITH THE
ODDS IS IT WORTH IT?
THAT BUCS HANGOVER, WE'LL KEEP
OUR EYES ON THAT.
IT'S ALWAYS HARD TO REPEAT IN
THE NFL.
RAMS, NEW ENERGY, NEW
QUARTERBACK.
I LIKE THOSE ODDS.
>> THIS STRATEGY HAS NOT WORKED
FOR EVERY TEAM BUT IT WORKED FOR
TEAMS WITH GENERATIONAL
QUARTERBACKS ON ROOKIE DEALS.
WE SAW RUSSELL WILSON WIN A
SUPER BOWL ON A ROOKIE DEAL.
WE WILL SEE LAMAR JACKSON IN
BALTIMORE WAYNE SUPER BOWL ON
HIS ROOKIE DEAL.
HE'S ON THE FINAL YEAR OF HIS
DEAL, HE'S LOOKING FOR A HUGE
PAY DAY BUT IT ALLOWS BALTIMORE
TO BE COMPETITIVE.
THEY ADDED SAMMY WATKINS, A
VERSATILE RECEIVER ON THE
OFFENSIVE END.
THEY DESIGNED BALTIMORE'S SCHEME
TO MAXIMIZE LAMAR JACKSON'S
TALENTS.
I THINK THIS YEAR, CONTRACT
YEAR, MY DUDE WILL PROBABLY GET
BETWEEN 30 MILLION AND 40
MILLION NEXT YEAR.
THIS IS THE YEAR TO DO IT.
THEY HAVE AN MVP AND
GENERATIONAL TALENT.
GIVE ME THE BALTIMORE RAVENS AT
PLUS 1400.
GREG, WHO DO YOU LIKE TO WIN THE
SUPER BOWL?
TELL ME ABOUT THE COMMENTS.
>> THE COMMENTS ARE ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
SWEENA IS BACK ROCKING THE
CARDINALS AND KYLE MURRAY.
CAMERON DEVAULT, ALREADY BOUGHT
THE 49ers SUPER BOWL CAP.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
CABBIE, I HAVE ONE MORE IN HERE.
K. POTS IS ROCKING WITH THE
BUFFALO BILLS.
LET ME GIVE AWAY THIS 250 DK
DOLLARS.
>> LET'S GET IT.
>> LET ME GIVE AWAY THIS 250 --
>> APPRECIATE YOUR GENEROSITY
TODAY.
THE AUDIENCE LOVES YOU, MAN.
YOU ALWAYS COME WITH GIFTS.
>> GOT TO TAKE CARE OF THE
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, I'M A MAN OF
THE PEOPLE.
I'M A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
HERE WE GO.
F. FLORES 9, ROCKING WITH THE
RAIDERS.
UNFORTUNATELY.
JUST KIDDING.
THEY SAY GOOD LUCK CONTAINING
THIS OFFENSE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU F. FLORES 9.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH 250 DK
DOLLARS.
HERE WE GO.
>> WHAT DO YOU GOT?
>> MY PICK TO WIN NFL
CHAMPIONSHIP, I WILL ROCK WITH
THE BUFFALO BILLS.
>> OKAY.
>> ROCKING WITH THE BUFFALO
BILLS.
I LIKE MY GUY, ALLEN OUT THERE.
I LIKE JOSH ALLEN.
LIKE WHAT HE DID LAST YEAR.
THEIR DEFENSE IS GOOD.
THEY HAVE A GOOD DEFENSE.
STEFON DIGGS OUT WIDE.
I THINK THEY HAVE WHAT IT TAKES,
CABBIE, TO KNOCK OFF THE CHIEFS
THIS YEAR.
I DO.
I STRONGLY DO BELIEVE THAT.
WE'LL SEE.
I THINK THEY'LL TAKE A BIG STEP.
CONNOR TALKED ABOUT IT EARLIER
IN THE SHOW.
HE SAID SOME TEAMS THAT WE'RE
USED TO NOT BEING GOOD, THEY'RE
GOING TO BE GOOD THIS YEAR.
I STRONGLY BELIEVE BUFFALO WILL
BE ONE OF THOSE TEAMS.
IF THE NINERS ARE NOT DOING WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING,
BUFFALO.
>> I LIKE THE PICK.
EVERYTHING IN THE NFL IS
CYCLICAL, MAYBE IT'S BUFFALO'S
TIME THIS YEAR.
VISIT DRAFTKINGS FOR MORE ODDS
TO WIN THE SUPER BOWL.
IT'S TIME FOR THE BIG MOMENT.
THE BIG MOMENT FROM OCHOCINCO.
TELL THEM WHAT IS UP.
>> WE'VE BEEN GIVING AWAY
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS IN BURGERS
ALL SHOW.
BUT RIGHT NOW, RIGHT NOW, CONNOR
AND CABBIE, IT'S TIME TO GIVE
AWAY FREE BURGERS FOR A YEAR
COURTESY OF CHAD JOHNSON
HIMSELF.
WE ASKED CHAD FOR HIS LOCK TO
WIN THE SUPER BOWL.
WE ASKED HIM, CHAD, WHO WILL WIN
THE SUPER BOWL?
GET IN THE COMMENTS, TELL ME WHO
YOU THINK HE CHOSE TO WIN THE
SUPER BOWL.
I WILL PICK ONE OF YOU WHO
GUESSES CORRECTLY TO WIN FREE
BURGERS FOR A YEAR.
>> WOW.
EVERYBODY IS VOTING.
LET'S TAKE A PEEK AT WHAT WEEK
ONE HAS TO OFFER.
WE JUST HIGHLIGHTED SIX MARQUEE
GAMES, MATCH-UPS.
AND IT STARTS WITH THE THURSDAY
NIGHT GAME.
DALLAS AND TAMPA BAY.
BUFFALO/PITTSBURGH.
CLEVELAND AND KANSAS CITY WHICH
SHOULD BE A GREAT ONE.
NEXT PAGE.
WE HAVE THE JETS AND CAROLINA.
WE WILL SEE THE RETURN OF
CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY.
THE SUNDAY NIGHT GAME, THE BEARS
AT THE RAMS.
AND THE MONDAY NIGHT GAME,
BALTIMORE RAVENS AND THE LAS
VEGAS RAIDERS.
CONNOR, WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE
WEEK ONE BET?
>> I'M CHASING THE OVERS ALL THE
WAY.
THAT'S WHAT I'M LOOKING AT.
>> OKAY.
>> I DON'T CARE ABOUT WHO WINS
OR LOSES IN MOST OF THESE GAMES.
I'M LOOKING AT THE OVERS GOING
FOR POINTS.
DALLAS AND TAMPA BAY, IT'S THE
FIRST GAME WE'LL SEE OF THE
YEAR.
DEFENSE MIGHT BE RUSTY.
MIGHT NOT BE UP TO SPEED.
WE GET THE RETURN OF DAK
PRESCOTT.
WE KNOW WHAT BRADY CAN DO.
I THINK WE'RE IN FOR A SHOOTOUT
ON NIGHT ONE WHERE WE GO OVER 52
POINTS.
>> LOVE THAT.
FOR WEEK ONE, I LIKE MY ROAD
DOGS.
ROAD DOGS DON'T GET THAT MUCH
LOVE.
I'M GOING WITH THE CHICAGO BEARS
PLUS 7.
ANDY DALTON AND JUSTIN FIELDS,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WIN THE GAME,
JUST COVER THE 7 POINTS.
I KNOW YOU'RE IN L.A., AS CONNOR
SAID EARLIER THEY HAVE THE BEST
DEFENSIVE PLAYER ON PLANET EARTH
IN NUMBER 99, BUT GAME MANAGE,
GET OUT WITH UNDER 7 POINTS.
GIVE ME THE BEARS AT PLUS 7.
GREG, WHAT'S YOUR FAVORITE WEEK
ONE MATCH-UP?
>> CABBIE, I'M THERE WITH YOU
BUT WITH A DIFFERENT TEAM.
I WILL TALK ABOUT THE SAME GAME
CONNOR TALKED ABOUT.
I THINK I WANT TO LEAN COWBOYS.
COWBOYS PLUS 6 1/2.
I TALKED ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE
SUPER BOWL HANGOVER WITH TAMPA
BAY WEEK ONE.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE GETTING
THEIR RINGS.
ALL THAT WILL BE, YOU KNOW,
TAKEN INTO EFFECT.
I THINK THE COWBOYS MIGHT KEEP
THIS ONE CLOSE.
ACTUALLY NOT MIGHT, I DO THINK
THEY'LL KEEP IT CLOSE.
I'M WILLING TO PUT MY MONEY ON
THE COWBOYS PLUS 6 1/2.
>> EVERYBODY LOVES OFFENSE.
HOPEFULLY WE GET GIANTS TUBS OF
POPCORN AND THAT GAME IS 52-49.
VISIT DRAFTKINGS FOR MORE WEEK
ONE ODDS.
LET'S GET TO THE MOMENT THAT
EVERYBODY HAS BEEN WAITING FOR.
FREE BURGERS FOR A YEAR, G.
MONEY.
WHO IS THIS LUCKY PERSON?
>> CABBIE, FREE BURGERS FOR A
YEAR.
LET ME LOOK.
LET ME LOOK INTO THESE COMMENTS.
I'LL GIVE AWAY SOME HOODIES AND
THEN THE FREE BURGER FORCE A
YEAR.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I SEE KING OF SPORTS 21 SAYS
LOVE THE PANTHERS, SAM DARNOLD
GOING AGAINST HIS FORMER TEAM.
PANTHERS WEEK ONE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
CABBIE, ACTUALLY, LET ME PULL UP
A VIDEO.
LET ME PULL UP THIS VIDEO REAL
QUICK BEFORE WE GET -- LET'S
PULL UP THE VIDEO, GUYS.
>> MY LOCK TO WIN THE SUPER
BOWL?
TAMPA BAY.
IF THE TAMPA BAY BUCCANEERS
DON'T WIN THE SUPER BOWL BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TOM, THEY HAVE THE
GREATEST CHANCE REGARDLESS OF
WHAT ANY OTHER TEAMS DO, I'LL
GIVE THEM McDONALD'S.
>> WHAT'S THAT NOW?
>> CHAD TOOK TAMPA BAY, CABBIE.
CHAD TOOK TAMPA BAY.
SOMEONE WHO TOOK THE BUCS.
SOMEONE WHO TOOK THE BUCS IS
WALKING AWAY WITH FREE BURGERS
FOR A YEAR.
I'M GOING TO GET IN THESE
COMMENTS.
>> LISTEN, IT'S DID-- I LOVE
OCHO'S CONFIDENCE AND SOMETIMES
HE TAKE BOLD SWINGS, BUT GOING
BACK-TO-BACK?
THAT'S LIKE -- CONNOR SAID IT,
IT'S SO HARD TO DO.
CHAD PLAYED IN THE NFL.
HE KNOWS PERSONALLY HOW HARD IT
WOULD BE FOR A TEAM TO WIN
BACK-TO-BACK.
TAMPA BAY?
GREAT SQUAD.
EVERYBODY IS RETURNING.
I DON'T KNOW, CONNOR WHAT DO YOU
THINK ABOUT THAT SUPER BOWL
PICK?
>> YOU JUST DON'T GET THAT KIND
OF INJURY LUCK YEAR AFTER YEAR.
>> RIGHT?
>> THAT'S WHAT THE PROBLEM IS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE AN OLDER
TEAM.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF YOUNGER
TALENT, BUT AT KEY POSITIONS
THEY'RE A VETERAN TEAM.
I KNOW THEY'RE A DEEP ROSTER,
ESPECIALLY AT WIDE RECEIVER,
THEY HAVE A GOOD OFFENSIVE LINE,
BUT I ALWAYS HAVE FEAR OF SUPER
BOWL CHAMPIONS COMING INTO
ANOTHER YEAR AND STAYING HEALTHY
AGAIN.
THE ODDS AREN'T IN YOUR FAVOR,
AND OFTEN WITH INJURIES, THE
LUCK IS NOT IN YOUR FAVOR.
>> G. MONEY?
>> LET ME GET BACK INTO THESE
COMMENTS.
I'VE BEEN SAYING IT ALL SHOW.
I DON'T THINK TAMPA BAY IS GOING
TO WIN.
I THINK THEY'LL HAVE A SUPER
BOWL HANGOVER.
LET ME GET BACK INTO THE
COMMENTS.
WE'RE AT ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PARTS OF THE SHOW.
WE'LL GIVE AWAY BURGERS FOR A
YEAR HERE.
RITCHIE RICH 21 SAYS
BACK-TO-BACK, LET'S GET IT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
WIRG SAYS LET'S GO.
LET'S GO.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
I'LL GIVE YOU A HOODIE FOR THAT.
GOOD VIBES.
HERE WE GO.
PIERRE C. SAID IF THEY MAKE IT
TO THE SUPER BOWL, YEAH, THEY
AIN'T NO STOPPING BRADY.
I TOTALLY AGREE.
LET ME GEIVE AWAY THESE FREE
BURGERS FOR A YEAR.
HERE WE GO.
NEXT ONE I SELECT IS FREE
BURGERS FOR A YEAR.
THE PERSON THAT IS WINNING FREE
BURGERS FOR A YEAR, KING 12.
KING 12.
THEY SAID TAMPA BAY.
THEY ARE ROCKING WITH TAMPA BAY,
TAMPA BAY, CHAD JOHNSON.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH FREE
BURGERS FOR A YEAR.
>> ENJOY THOSE DELICIOUS CARBS.
SO JEALOUS.
IF YOU LEARNED ANYTHING TODAY,
LET IT BE THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WAIT FOR FOOTBALL SEASON TO GET
IN ON THE ACTION.
GET ON DRAFTKINGS AND BET YOUR
FAVORITE FUTURES AND BET THE WIN
TOTALS FOR YOUR FAVORITE TEAMS.
DRAFTKINGS HOOKED US UP AND
GIVING AN ODDS BOOST TO THE TEAM
MOST BET AND KNOCKING A WIN OFF
OF THE TOTAL.
G. MONEY, YOU CAN'T TO GIVE AWAY
A FEW MORE HOODIES BEFORE WE GET
OUT OF HERE?
>> WHY NOT.
>> MAYBE TWO MORE.
>> B. HOLTE 07, COULD SEE BRADY
FINISHING HIS CAREER GOING
BACK-TO-BACK.
>> THAT WOULD BE SICK.
>> SKIP JONES, TAMPA BAY WENT ON
A HOT STREAK.
IT WON'T HAPPEN AGAIN THIS YEAR.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, SKIP JONES.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CABBIE, THAT'S TWO.
>> YEAH.
THAT JOHN ELWAY WALKING OFF IN
THE SUNSET BACK-TO-BACK
CHAMPIONSHIPS WOULD BE
INCREDIBLE.
THE PERFECT ENDING FOR TOM
BRADY'S CAREER, IF HE WANTS TO
RETIRE.
I FEEL HE WANTS TO PLAY UNTIL
HE'S 50.
WE'LL ALL BE CHEERING HIM ON.
ALONGSIDE GREG IVORY AND CONNOR
RODGERS, I'M CABBIE RICHARDS.
CONGRATS TO OUR WINNERS AND
EVERYBODY WHO TAPPED IN FOR BR
DROPZONE.
LOOK AT TWO VERY DIFFERENT BUT
EQUALLY VALID APPROACHES MAKING
PICKS FROM OUR FRIENDS AT
DRAFTKINGS.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF MVP TALK
GOING AROUND THE GAME OF
FOOTBALL.
>> HEAR ME OUT.
>> I DON'T LISTEN TO OTHER
PEOPLE.
I MAKE MY OWN PREDICTIONS.
>> THE RUNNING GAME WAS NOWHERE
TO BE FOUND FOR THE STEELERS
LAST YEAR.
HE'S PROBABLY GOING TO BE
PITTSBURGH'S TOP RUNNING BACK.
♪
WITH THAT WORK LOAD HE COULD GET
20 PLUS TOUCHES A GAME.
THAT EQUALS STATS.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
♪